talking voters about the candidates and
the issues in today's primary so he
tagged along with voters there on an ice
fishing trip is that fun we'll see the
weather might be a factor today why
because snow is in the forecast so let's
go back to cafe Lorraine which I learned
Tony in the last half-hour means Queen
did you know that thank you Tony
it means green hey good morning Gail I
got to tell you ice fishing is very fun
and I have it on good authority that you
can come out anytime and you'll be
welcome
can't wait coffee or kafele Rin is
terrific the croissants already sold out
but that is not why President Trump was
here last night he was here last night
because New Hampshire could emerge as a
key battleground in November he lost
here by the slimmest margin of any state
in 2016 and the voters here are famously
independent just 28 percent are
registered as Democrats just 29 percent
as Republicans and the largest number 42
percent officially undeclared because
those voters are allowed to participate
in today's Democratic primary New
Hampshire can be hard to pull so we
found if you want to get a sense of how
people are feeling it helps if you break
the ice on a winter day in New Hampshire
there aren't too many places to go
looking for voters but over an ice
fishing hole and Concord is one of them
how many maggots you put on the hook I'm
gonna put three on right now and that's
where we met Dennis Witcher anymore
you're a hunting guide primarily you're
a fishing guide mhm
you're Republican you're Democrat yes
sort of sort of says it all when it
comes to the New Hampshire primary as
many sort of Democrats review a field of
candidates they only sort of like I'm
struggling with the presidential race
this year
what's the struggle over the division in
this country is probably the biggest
issue that I have right now it's just
heartbreaking whoa whoa okay up here we
found reeling in fish can be easier than
reeling in votes healthcare is one of
your top issues I'm self-employed so
it's expensive it's very expensive
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders seem
to have Medicare for all plans right
yeah free at the point of service mm-hmm
sounds pretty good no well how we gonna
pay for it another major campaign
big felt unavoidable this is 40 degrees
I've got my coat open but it's not
supposed to be this hot no no it's it's
global warming come on say that with a
smile what do you think do you don't
really believe it's a joke you got to be
kidding me Tim are you with Dennis on
that point no so your biggest issues are
in order political polarization health
care health care mmm health care and
climate I mean
you mean the hoax is that your friend
here says it's not affecting your
business just climate change I mean the
Trump administration is rolling back
protections on our waters as more
considers who might be able to help him
Witcher has his own mixed feelings about
the person now in charge President Trump
what do you think of his character
that's a tough call as he gave it some
thought oh I got one there you go Tony's
fish this could be dinner oh I'm not
gonna grab with my bare hand then back
to the topic at hand I think on a
personal level he has a good character
but his public appearance it's pretty
crude do you think he's always honest I
think he's an honest person but he sure
does tell a lot of lies
for now which er is willing to look past
it all for one reason how do you think
the economy is doing oh it's
unbelievable
I think his trade policy's you know the
tariffs you know dealing with China has
helped a lot and he's managed to keep
the farmers happy we decided the warm-up
in Manchester where President Trump has
even stronger support what's your
favorite thing that he's gotten done
everything all of it what about you
let's get to have my kids college funds
leaps thrived yeah yeah along with our
401 is my wife's myself but also much
stronger opposition from primary voters
like Deborah's holes and just Morello an
ability to beat Trump is a big
qualification for anybody it's not that
I don't like him back on the pond which
er and more are as divided as anyone but
only politically so what advice do you
have for the rest of the country to get
along the way you two guys are go
fishing yeah thanks life pretty easy
that's pretty good advice there for all
of America just go fishing but today in
New Hampshire people are voting and if
there were any doubt more and more
people are coming into the cafe with
these stickers I voted one for all
unlike Iowa it's important to point out
that this is a traditional one-person
one-vote secret ballot here's your
sticker back sir these three folks have
already voted this morning none of them
are talking about who they voted though
they close the curtain it's their
business that's a tradition here in New
Hampshire a lot of independents a lot of
in undeclared voters we talked to them
as part of that ice fishing piece and
our trip to the bars of Manchester and
Concord
we heard a lot of support for Tulsi
Gabbard believe it or not she's not
pulling that well but she is a candidate
who defies easy definition left or right
and one thing we found here in New
Hampshire is that is definitely true of
the state itself hi Tony it sounds like
a lot of us need to go fishing also like
the secretary of state of New Hampshire
saying to you you can't hack a pencil
yes so hopefully it'll go a lot more
smooth smoother in New Hampshire than it
and nice fish Tony bring it home